I can't think of a clever opener on this
one so let's just roll the credits hello
folks so this one is a patreon sponsored
review it was something that I had no
real awareness of that initially when I
saw the request it struck me as a little
odd um and then I were actually watched
it and I definitely now need to talk
about it so what I was requested to
review through a patreon sponsorship is
an episode from the British series
accused and it's an episode from the
second series called Tracy's story now
if you don't know accused because I
didn't before I watched this I've never
seen any of it before it's um it is a
crime show that removes a very large
portion of what takes up the majority of
the runtime in most episodes of crime
shows which is there's no investigation
we don't deal with the police it's not
about finding the perpetrator what what
the format of the show is that you meet
the people who were in some way involved
in the crime that was committed we learn
about them we learn about the the
context around them and the events and
we lead up to and and get to whatever
the actual crime was and then it's
basically taken for granted that police
got involved investigation happened
people were arrested and then it jumps
to the verdict of a trial and what
happens to the accused
so Tracy's story star Sean Bean and he
plays a transvestite and/or crossdresser
transvestite is the term I see more
often used in the UK and
I'm gonna do something I don't usually
do which is that I'm probably gonna end
up referring to Tracy and Simon who are
the same person both played by Sean Bean
as different people and use different
pronouns for each of them
the reason I'm gonna do that is because
that's what the show and the and the
character themselves actually does when
Tracy were first assignment she refers
to him and the third person calls him he
and there's some similar dialogue
happens when Simon talks about Tracy
though there's a little bleed over going
that way but did Tracy Simon this person
treats these as separate and distinct
people and out of respect for the
character I kind of want to do the same
thing so before I get too much into this
that this is this is gonna end up
getting pretty personal so we're gonna
we're gonna present in a way that I
don't usually do more than once a month
on this channel which is in a more
blended fashion so for anyone who wasn't
already aware I currently identify as
gender-fluid I have a fluctuating sense
of self and gender but and I haven't
really talked a ton about this on this
channel before I sort of came to an
understanding of myself as being gender
fluid I basically was not similar from a
two to Tracy which was that I identified
as a cisgender male who would cross
dress and had a female persona but I
didn't think of myself as having an
alternate gender identity part of that
was for you know for a long time I
didn't really have a firm understanding
of of all the options available because
I thought well you're either cisgender
or you
transgender and I do not intend nor do I
believe I should be living full-time as
a woman so by default I must be
cisgender I now know that's not the case
but a lot of what I saw reflected in
Tracy as a character and the glimpses we
look at we see of her life and of the
simon side and of his life rang a lot of
bells and rang true and reminded me a
lot of my own experiences and wow i
can't say that the character of Tracy is
accurate to me as I am now or even as I
have been for the last I don't know five
years or so this is probably in while
not without being a hundred percent it's
probably the closest and most true and
respectful representation I have seen of
basically what I was maybe 10 years ago
and that was pretty amazing to see
there's a lot at play for what makes
Tracy so well realized as a character
and in terms of telling the story first
of all Sean Bean is amazing in this and
I as much as like he he carries this
performance incredibly I want to give
credit to as many departments as I can
because I think everybody stepped up and
portraying this character I think the
makeup is spot-on the kind of thing that
is liable to be done by someone in Simon
or Tracy's situation I felt the writing
was really great and so I don't I don't
know how much research was or wasn't
done by anybody involved in terms of
like interviewing transvestites or you
know anybody like what Tracy is I don't
know if they did that
but it certainly feels like that it
feels like somebody did their research
whether it was the actor the director
the writers or all of the above
somebody to their research on this and
it shows so some of the things about
Tracy that are really amazingly captured
there's this sense of both freeness and
desperation to be actively living as
Tracy what I mean by that is you very
much get the sense that Simon is simply
existing and Tracy is living and I think
that's that again it certainly was very
true to my experience for a long time
because if I mean if you're so closeted
that you won't even go out anywhere
that's never been my experience but if
you're closeted to the point of you have
pretty firm barriers between your
masculine and your feminine existences
and you don't make all that many people
aware of both generally it means is that
as a man you're not making people aware
of your feminine side because you know
Sean Bean doesn't pass I don't you know
when I was trying to look as completely
feminine as possible I didn't pass I
still don't so you know anyone who sees
you in a feminine mode can probably
guess oh yeah
day to day you're you're a man but you
don't let people who only know your
masculine side and on the other side of
that and for that for that kind of
closeted it rang incredibly true because
Tracy is not going to get all dressed up
shave your body shave herself and put on
makeup and wear heels if she's not gonna
also do something so she's gonna happen
she's gonna go out she's gonna dance
she's gonna date she is going to bring
people back to her place and have fun
because otherwise what is the point in
doing all of this if you're gonna do all
that stuff you kind of want to
live a very full life doing that and
that can in some ways enhance whatever
lack of fulfillment you're getting in a
more day-to-day masculine life and what
I mean by that is Simon has to do all
the boring stuff he has to go to work to
a job he doesn't really like he has to
buy groceries pay taxes all the things
that feel
draining about day to day life that's
what Simon has to do he just exists
Tracy gets to live and that is just kind
of a reality of it and I do I do feel
like the show did a fairly good job at
illustrating that without making it feel
like and Simon is supposed to be Tracy
we see very clearly that Simon is
happier as Tracy but Simon also isn't
living a complete existence as Tracy
he's living it very selectively only the
fun parts as Tracy and what I love about
that is that this show captured that and
in a way that felt real and felt true
but it never actually says it nobody
sits down and talks about this but it
was still fully captured and was present
all the way through this this character
is just amazing and and Sean beans
performance to come back to that he did
such a great job because he did what
most men who when they they take on a
feminine side of themselves do which is
to not only pitch up your voice but also
adjust your cadence and your rhythm and
sort of the way with which you work your
way through a sentence and then you
adjust your your body posture and you
know maybe the way that that your face
tends to fall all of those things kind
of shift as you embrace your feminine
side and he was able to do
that in a way that I've not really seen
captured on film before because he
wasn't you know oh I fell fabulous
around the place which is the kind of
thing that you know people who don't do
research who don't know the reality of
this kind of life tend to depict it as
it becomes a deliberate caricature or an
exaggeration or a drag queen or you know
that they and that's not what it is
that's not the reality for well it
wasn't my reality at any rate and for my
experience talking to a lot of people
who have had lives and experiences
similar to mine it wasn't theirs either
so for him to capture so well that
essence of a distinct shift but not
exaggerating so much that it ever felt
played as a joke or for laughs or like
he didn't get it
it absolutely plays like Sean Bean got
it and that was really amazing to see on
film I mean it I'm not sure it's the
kind of thing I ever expected like to
see accurately portrayed on film because
I didn't think anybody cared enough to
try and get it right so oh god okay that
was unexpected um-hmm but it's it's an
astounding performance an amazing
character and so fully realized on every
level and every detail and also not
exaggerating the fact that as much as
Tracy may be living with and Simon is
that there there's still at times a
hollowness to that especially when it
comes to sex and that's actually another
thing I was surprised that the show got
as well as it did which was sort of a
kind of understanding the kind of person
who would be attracted to someone like
Tracy because like the way that some
people will mock
someone like Tracy or someone like me is
with these these sort of throwings of
you no one would ever want to be with
you you don't look like a woman you
don't pass for a moon why would anyone
want to be with you well there are
people who do and some are able to do so
in a somewhat respectful way some are
very very sleazy about it if they do
exist but it is still ultimately a bit
of a fetid tide fetishization of you as
a person so there is kind of a
hollowness or superficiality to it and
again without actually stopping the
story to talk about that I felt that the
show captured that very well too and it
and it makes a lot of sense why Tracy
latches on so much to the character of
Tony because he's one of the few who
comes back and wants to see her more
than once he's he usually has to drink
before he does it
which again not all that unreflecting of
the reality for men who are attracted to
transvestites and and cross dressers and
who are often incredibly confused about
themselves now pretty much all the way
through this been talking about the
character of Tracy I haven't talked a
lot about the plot and I'm not gonna go
into a lot of detail about it because I
don't think I need to talk about
spoilers in order to to highlight what
what matters to me about this the thing
is I didn't the plot is fine but the
sorts of exaggerations about the way
people who see Tracy react or the way in
which certain things around the kind of
person Tracy is can escalate the way
that those are slight not horrendously
but slightly exaggerated for dramatic
purposes is kind of necessitated by the
format of the show like there has to be
a crime that is committed in the context
and the circumstances with the
characters that we have come to know so
things have to escalate to the point
that that happens and the the things
that are done in terms of establishing
you know how people react and respond to
Tracy again speaking only from my own
experience they were a little bit
exaggerated and and and I'm not gonna
say that you know no crossdresser or a
transvestite or trans woman or or any
kind of like non gender conforming
presenting person doesn't get harassed
in the way that Tracy we see Tracy get
harassed but in my experience to have it
happen to that degree and like have
trouble with the and like I'm what I'm
gonna talk about here is very early on
so it's not really but like to have
trouble with the cab driver and and go
to a bar that you I'm I have to presume
she had scoped up or been to before and
felt was safe because she's a girl who
goes out she would know where it's okay
to go and yet to still run into people
there who were gonna hassle her to the
great degree that she gets hassled and
then other things that happen later on
and then build in the way they do I'm
not gonna say that kind of stuff doesn't
happen but it is the kind of slightly
dramatic exaggeration like all this
stuff like happening to the same person
in this in this window of time you're a
little bit like again it's not bad but I
think the thing is because Tracy feels
so real to me the things that happen
that make the narrative slightly on the
slightly less real creates a little bit
of a disconnect for me because the
narrative and pas are fine there is
absolutely nothing wrong with them but
they are just that little bit removed
from reality for the purposes of getting
because of the dramatic necessities of
the format whereas Tracy does not feel
exaggerated to me at all she feels so
real and so true and that there that
creates an immediate comparison and it's
funny because as
it got towards the end I found myself
incredibly worried and fearful for Tracy
and my initial thought as that was
happening because I'd been watching it
and sort of like knowing that I loved
her and and Simon I don't want to
undercut the the performance of Simon as
well and capturing that side of it but I
knew that I loved this character but
that I was kind of like going back and
forth on the narrative and the plot and
the story that was being told with them
again not that it was Babbitt it wasn't
grabbing me as much and then towards the
end sort of being like really feeling in
my heart like true genuine concern my
initial thought was well the story must
be doing something right but then on
reflection I realized no the story's
just being functional it's the character
that I am incredibly invested in and
that is the absolute home run of this
and again I don't want to knock the plot
I don't want to knock the story but that
felt like it fell into into the
expectations and the way I've seen these
things depicted that kind of been the
way it always has been that I that was
what I expected to see whereas Tracy's
so vastly exceeded what I expected to
see that that the other elements of the
of the episode kind of pale in
comparison but I found this to be an
amazing and honestly touching piece of
work as far as a character depiction
because it captures the duality while
still understanding that even as much as
Simon and Tracy may put up a barrier
between each other that this isn't like
the personalities they are the same
person they have parallel and similar
desires as much as as they try to have
that wall between like I will i remember
that wall i remember that wall
separating a masculine and a feminine
side and over time I just let it kind of
fall into disrepair I never had the like
the proper catharsis of like taking a
wrecking ball to it but I remember when
it was there and this is the best
depiction of scene that captures that by
a country mile
I can't even remember seeing anything
else that even tried to capture what
this captures and for this to do it so
well it I'm really glad I saw this until
the patreon port was supporter who
commissioned me to see it I thank you I
think that that's all I can say is thank
you because I probably never would have
seen this otherwise so I think I'll wrap
it up there
Tracy's story and how sort of a
spotlight on lgbtq+ representation a
very specific sliver of it that I have
never seen depict it as well as I did
here so that will wrap it up for this
one have you seen this do you have
anything else that you've seen besides
this that you feel is depicting this
kind of thing and is of this kind of
caliber because I'd love to see other
suggestions whatever your thoughts may
be drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of to do there's buttons there's
lengths the patreon which obviously this
video is effectively sponsored by that
links down in the description a whole
bunch of other links the the book that I
wrote about being gender fluid and being
a crossdresser there's a link for that
in the description so all
it's available down there check it out
or if you don't want to you don't have
to because at the end of the day you are
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]